le nil le plus long fleuve du monde avec
l'amazone suit son cours sans remous et
pourtant la question du partage de ses
eaux est en train de provoquer une
véritable guerre froide entre l'ethiopie
et l'egypte cela fait huit ans que
l'ethiopie s'affairent à construire le
plus gros barrage hydroélectrique
d'afrique
il est en béton mesure 175 mètres dos et
produira plus de 6000 mégawatts
d'électricité sont tout près de 5
milliards de dollars 70% du barrage
serait déjà complétée ici dans la ville
de baar dalle au bord du nil la
construction du barrage est vue d'un bon
oeil
l'ethiopie est un grand pays dit il il
n'y a pas d'autre option
l'électricité va développer notre
économie avec ses 105 millions
d'habitants la demande en électricité
augmente de 30% chaque année le nil bleu
prend sa source en ethiopie rejoint le
nil blanc au soudan avant de se jeter
dans la mer méditerranée en egypte 86%
des eaux du nil vienne d'ethiopie le
pays jadis associé à la famine fait le
pari de sortir des cycles de sécheresse
de ne plus faire partie des pays les
plus pauvres de la planète pour devenir
un pays exportateur d'énergie
mais ce barrage est aussi surnommé le
barrage de la discorde
il inquiète légers touchés o'neal a
toujours été perçu comme une déclaration
de guerre contre le caire
80% de l'agriculture du pays dépend du
fleuve et les autorités craignent que
l'approvisionnement en eau diminue pour
l'egypte
il y va de ses sécurité alimentaire et
retenant à l'auteur georges frêche si le
débit d'eau baisse dit elle une
réduction de 2% va affecter un million
de personnes
ce sont les plus pauvres les fermiers
qui vont écoper ajoutent elles avec le
réchauffement climatique et les vagues
de chaleur
notre agriculture a besoin de plus d'eau
dit il le mois dernier le président 6,6
écrit sur twitter
l'egypte est déterminé à défendre son
droit sur l'eau alors à gan magog la
tension est telle qu'une médiation
internationale présidée par les états
unis
et maintenant place les observateurs
doivent être impartiaux et indépendants
soutient le ministre éthiopien me kelly
qui dispensent m'expliquer nous
discutons de bonne foi dit le
représentant soudanais le nil est un
lien éternel entre nos pays renchérit le
ministre égyptien
mais dans les coulisses ce barrage
empoisonne les relations des pays
les dirigeants se livrent un véritable
bras de fer pourtant une déclaration de
principe avait été signée en 2015 entre
le soudan l'egypte et l'ethiopie
garantissant un partage équitable des
eaux docteur yacco barça noé professeur
de sciences politiques à l'université
d'addis ababa il fait partie de l'équipe
d'experts éthiopiens qui négocie avec
l'egypte si les pays veulent qu'elle est
en guerre à cause de l'eau ce serait
insensé dit il pourquoi se battre alors
qu'il ya mille et une façons de négocier
une entente qui serait bénéfique pour
tous mais déjà en 2013 l'egypte n'écarte
pas l'idée d'une intervention militaire
le real sont mortes plus qu on pourrait
soutenir les mouvements d'indépendance
et profiter des problèmes internes qui
fragilise le pays dit-il
on mettrait de la pression sur le
gouvernement éthiopien sept réunions
censées être à huis clos a été diffusée
en direct sur les ondes égyptienne et a
eu l'effet d'une bombe
l'egypte tente rethel de déstabiliser
l'ethiopie pour protéger son
approvisionnement en eau l'ancien
premier ministre éthiopien mêlés zenawi
avait déclaré en 2001 la pasta le texte
en belgique on continue en juillet 2018
l'ethiopie pleure le directeur du
barrage 6 mai new bakala le visage de
cet ambitieux projet
voilà il est mort crie cet homme
l'ingénieur a été retrouvé mort dans sa
voiture avec une balle dans la tête
la police conclut au suicide les travaux
du barrage était censé être déjà
terminée sa finalisation est maintenant
prévue pour 2022
jam one piece belle tu vois le building
de ce pôle est quand le barrage sera
complétée dit-il le remplissage se fera
en plusieurs étapes
il va se faire graduellement pour que
les effets ne se fasse pas trop sentir
au soudan et en egypte l'egypte espère
que le remplissage se fasse très
lentement alors que les turcs yves
produire de l'électricité le plus
rapidement possible
en l'absence d'un accord viable
plusieurs craignent que ce barrage
provoque une guerre sans merci entre les
deux pays
ils ont jusqu'au 15 janvier pour sortir
de l'impasse